about 30 minutes ago adam schefter
reported that
um the seattle seahawks are uh in a
position to push
to sign antonio brown after his
reinstatement in week 8. he's curious
you can comment on that and your
potential interest in antonio
we have we have endeavored to be in on
everything that's going on and john has
done a marvelous job of always being
tuned in to what's happening
and uh and this is this is no exception
you know
so we'll see what happens you know as we
go forward but uh
we're we're tuned into what's happening
there
let's be careful from yesterday at his
press conference he went even farther
last night on sirius xm nfl radio he
said
we're there we're in it and we know
what's happening so
we're there we're in it it isn't settled
yet we don't know where it's going to go
we're always on the ready to compete to
get guys and so this is one of those
chances and we'll see what happens
this one doesn't surprise me last year
they were interested in antonio brown
they were interested in josh gordon they
signed josh gordon there was that cloud
over antonio brown because
no one knew whether or not the league
was going to put him on the commissioner
exempt list there was that vibe
that that's what the league was going to
do so as a result and this is what
drives me crazy don't get me started i'm
going to get started
he served last year a 14-game unpaid
suspension because the league wouldn't
tell
teams whether or not they would put him
on the commissioner exemplars so nobody
would sign him yeah right they should
have told the teams if they weren't
going to do it so he could play last
year while everything was playing out
the league got to have it both ways and
what and see he should have gotten
credit
you're going to suspend him eight games
he served 14 he should be good to go
at the start of the 2020 season but
that's not how it works because the nfl
does whatever they want to do when it
comes to these kinds of situations
that's just fact i'm not being critical
that's just fact they do whatever they
want to do
and it's hard for the players to do
anything about it now that antonio brown
is almost available to come back and
it's as of week 8 that he'll be able to
be signed
it sure looks like the seahawks are in
it chris and as we said yesterday
there's a chance that that will spark
other teams
to become interested if for no reason
other than to block the seahawks from
getting
well yeah i mean that that's that would
be a big time move i'm sure there'd be
some teams in the nfc that'll be looking
at it going wait do we want to get in on
this do we really want to let them have
antonio brown maybe we need him
you know again i'll throw green bay out
there that should be one of those teams
thinking about that
but um makes sense it really does
you know one like new england i think
seattle has the type of culture that
it's just not they're not going to be
affected by antonio brown or anything
like that it certainly
wasn't an issue in new england the issue
was of course they didn't know about
some of the things that
maybe antonio brown and his
representation didn't tell him some
things that were going on behind the
scenes
but it wasn't about not being able to
fit in the culture or bringing him in
that way
hey the seahawks got you know they got
to make some sort of move
right i don't know if they can make
enough trades to help their defense out
so what's the next thing you do after
that you just go
let's just score more points let's just
score more because that's what we got to
do that's the strength of our team our
quarterback our passing game
and let's make it to basically where
nobody can match up with us in football
across the board and i understand where
they're going because i think at this
late in the game
i don't know maybe some defensive
players will be out there worth trading
for because of next year's salary cap
and issue and all that
but i think that's going to be tough to
do because they got to balance next
year's salary cap and all those type of
things so
this is the next best best thing get a
guy that's on the street and hopefully
he's ready to go and can help their team
if it comes to that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports